good evening my name is nari woods and
I'm Dean of the Blavatnik School of
Government at Oxford University
it gives me particular pleasure to be
moderating a debate on the question
Western liberal democracy would be wrong
for China in establishing a School of
Government what's struck me is how much
that question is being asked both
outside-in and inside-out around the
world how many times in the United
States and Europe I've been asked if it
wouldn't be better to move to a model of
authoritarian or benign dictatorship and
how many times in China and elsewhere
I've been asked searching questions
about democracy so this is a truly
timely debate you will be casting your
vote at the end of the debate for those
of you who are coming to this as their
first intelligence squared debate you
tear your ticket in two and you can cast
your bait either for or against
depending on which of these fantastic
panelists has persuaded you that their
side of this argument is right if you
just want to sit on the fence you can
put your entire ticket on the box in the
box but I think that's unsporting so I'd
urge you all to to boldly take make your
vote I think it's it's also timely that
we're having this debate the day after
America's election I think in the minds
of many of us are questions about
whether it's necessarily the case that
the skills it takes to win an election
are not the skills it takes to govern a
country well I think many of us are
asking whether it's a good use of half a
billion dollars put in by companies to
purchase some would say their
preferences in government and that
likewise the non-democratic
systems of the world have their
counterpart in the injections of
billions perhaps less transparently into
control over their leadership I think in
both west and east there's a real issue
about what is the system which best
protects minorities and the very poorest
in society we're in one system they
might have legal rights which aren't
enforced and in the other they don't
have the legal rights in the first place
so these these are the questions I'm
very much hoping our debate will take us
to tonight so without further ado I'm
going to call on Jiang Weiwei as our
first speaker he's senior fellow at the
chinkyu Institute author of the China
Wave the rise of a civilizational state
Shang Weiwei will be known to many of
you as the senior translator - Deng Chao
ping but perhaps you don't realize that
he spent the last twenty four years or
he spent 24 years I should say living
and working in Europe and when I asked
Jiang Weiwei why what was it about
Europe that he most liked he said it's
the taste for everything old and the
architecture so Jiang Weiwei we look
forward to your argument for the motion
that Western liberal democracy would be
wrong for China
Thank You professor Woods for your very
kind introduction we are living in an
extraordinary kind of history yesterday
us held its presidential election and
tomorrow
China will hold its eating's party
Congress which were unveiled China's new
generation of leaders the Western media
tends to present the two events as a
sharp contrast between OPEC communist
state beset with crises and the
transparent dynamic liberal democracy
behind this very superficial contrast is
a widely held view that Western liberal
democracy represents the ultimate best
political system or in professor
fukuyama's worth the end of history and
therefore China is viewed always as a
kind of enlarged the Belarus awaiting a
color revolution in the transition
towards liberal democracy short of that
China will be hopeless but this squirrel
fort is faced with a mind-boggling
question it's forever pessimistic
forecasts about China China's collapse
tends to be always wrong and after three
decades misplaced predictions about
China it's time now to think outside the
box to consider seriously the scene of
our debate today Western liberal
democracy would be wrong for China to my
mind there are at least five reasons for
this argument first common sense with a
population larger than we combined the
populations of North America Europe
Russia Japan and more with no tradition
of liberal democracy whatsoever
with a fresh memory of the
stating breakup of the Soviet Union
Russia was only 1/10 of China size in
terms of population with long memory of
upheavals throughout China's long and
modern history and China's fear of
upheavals is based on common sense
indeed the country may well become
uncover nerble if it adopted Western
political model China is not an enlarged
Belarus China is a civilization of state
is the size of roughly every 100 average
of European states it's a product of
hundreds of states amalgamated into one
of its long history an inaccurate
analogy would be something like the
Asian Roman Empire continuing to this
day as unify the modern state with a
centralized government modern economy or
its diverse traditions and cultures and
huge population that all speak Latin to
be frank this kind of state cannot Ford
one-person one-vote a multi-party system
even the European Union of 27 cannot
afford this kind of system if the
doctors cannot model it were either
become useless white elephant or end up
in disintegration second empirical
evidence China actually experimented
liberal democracy after its 1911
Republic Revolution but this experiment
turned out to be a devastating
catastrophe the country immediately
plunged into chaos and civil wars with
hundreds of political parties juggling
for power with warlords fighting each
other each supported by some foreign
powers with a shattered economy and
millions of lives lost in the decades to
come this kind of lesson is so sharp and
so fresh in the memory of the Chinese
today virtually China you often use the
word run they are afraid of blood
what did the run mean Johnny means chaos
and third performance chan has performed
arguably better than most liberal
democracies over the past three decades
especially in domains of great concern
to most Chinese people of course China
has its share of problems some very
serious but China's overall success is
beyond the doubt over the past three
decades child had performed better than
other developing countries combined in
terms of eradicating poverty 70% of
world poverty were radically in China
over the past 20 years Chan has
performed better than all the transition
economies combined so China's economy
increase 18 fold in the matter of three
decades compared with say Eastern Europe
roughly one fold Chan has also performed
better than many developed the countries
China has a large developed region
roughly 300 million people the size of
the United States which today in many
ways can compete with developed
countries and the first year cities like
Shanghai in this develop the region can
and should be able to compete with
London or New York fourth the liberal
democracy model itself is in deep
trouble assume in crisis of the crisis
for deeply indebted America to
distressed
Europe even with Obama's election
victory today I don't see any solution
to America's projected problems despite
some of its known strengths liberal
democracy as a institution has been
seriously eroded by such a prevailing
problems such as short-termism
single-minded populism excessive
influence of money especially United
States one dollar one vote
and influence of special interests every
her Lincoln's idea of government of the
people by the people for the people is
hardly achievable among liberal
democracies otherwise Joseph Stiglitz
Norbury economics Laurie would not have
complained he said American polity has
become austere 1%
by the 1% for the 1% this is why even
the advocate of end of history professor
Fukuyama said not long ago in the
Financial Times op-ed that united states
democracy has little to teach China now
fifths and my last point the channel
model without much fanfare Beijing has
actually introduced major reform into
its ways of political governance and
established a very elaborate system of
meritocracy which can be called
selection plus election across the whole
of China's political structure nothing
can better illustrate this meritocracy
system than the line up of the next
generation of Chinese political leaders
to be unveiled in the coming days
virtually all the candidate members of
China's Standing Committee the highest
decision body decision-making body of
China have served twice at the number
one of the Chinese province as you may
know given the size of China each
province is often four or five times of
the average European states it's by no
means it takes extraordinary talent and
skill to govern the Chinese state you
have to do it twice and perform well
before get ticket to end in to top
leadership I said with this kind of
meritocracy system in place as its case
now of course can be further improved or
can already guarantee such leaders like
George W Bush or japan's Prime Minister
Noda
we'll have no chance whatsoever to end
the top-level leadership it's a way
below the Chinese standards to be frank
the channel model is more about
leadership while the liberal democracy
mode seems more about showmanship China
is now capable planning for the next
generation while the other model
planning for next election or next 100
days China's meritocracy system indeed
challenges this stereotypical dichotomy
of democracy versus autocracy from the
Chinese upon our view the nature of the
state including its legitimacy has to be
defined by its substance that is by good
government's with competent leaders and
measured by what state can deliver and
toward extent people are satisfied
despite its deficiencies which could be
many the Chinese polity has ensured the
world's fastest growing economy over
three decades running and ensure the
vast improved living standards for most
Chinese as reviewed in the most recent
PW survey PW Washington based research
organization 82% Chinese feel optimistic
about the future of their country indeed
this status is so good it's way ahead of
for the Western liberal democracies
Winston Churchill's famous dictum
democracy is the worst form of
government except for those other forms
that have been tried may be true in the
Western political culture many Chinese
even paraphrase this phrase into what
Chinese call a shot or least bad option
when chances on political culture in
confusion tradition of meritocracy a
state should always strive for the best
of the
best solution and option it's by no
means easy but you have to try even you
meet half of these standards which is
already admirably so at this moment
China has succeeded in building up also
it's not perfect yet this kind of
meritocracy system will combine the best
option of selecting well tested leaders
and also introduced the least bad option
to ensure the actual bad leaders so
collective leadership through terms very
strict term limit age limit so I think
this kind of meritocracy is really a
competitive it may win out in this
global competition of ideas and good
governance and good democracy
China has learned so much from the West
and will continue to do so for its own
benefit
but it may be time now to use in helping
famous phrase to emancipate the mind and
learn a bit on the part of the West to
learn bit more about China and you will
learn bit from the chinese ideas and
practices Arabic strenuous they may
appear for its own benefit in conclusion
one man's medicine could be another
man's poison and Western liberal
democracy
may be great or less great for the West
but would be miserable in wrong for
country like China thank you very much
for your attention
our next speaker speaking against the
motion is the former chief secretary of
Hong Kong the first woman and the first
Chinese to hold this second highest
governmental position in Hong Kong Anson
Chan is someone who learned her politics
at home she and her twin sister and six
brothers contending and with a
remarkable woman as a mother a mother
who was widowed in her mid-30s and
raised the eight children as well as
carving herself out a career as a famous
calligraphy and painter we're lucky to
have Anson Chan here today Thank You
Anne
I like to thank intelligence squared for
inviting me to participate in this
debate addressing the motion that
Western liberal democracy would be bad
for China
I think the selection of today's date
could not be more apt neatly sandwiched
between yesterday's u.s. presidential
election and tomorrow's opening of the
18th National Congress of the Communist
Party of China that will usher in the
next generation of Chinese leadership
the contrast between the nail-biting
finish of one with the carefully
choreographed outcome of the other could
hardly be more stark I like to begin by
addressing the subtext to the motion
namely that the Chinese model of
government has done more for the Chinese
than the Western model of government
ever could this rather presupposes that
within this room we share a common
understanding of what is meant by the
Chinese model of government and the term
Western liberal democracy as I doubt
this is so permit me to give my
perspective 63 years on from the end of
the civil war in China the Communist
Party still remains firmly in control
however the policies of the last 30
years in particular the evolution of
capitalism with Chinese characteristics
have moved light-years away from the
ideologies of the Mao era which thrived
on constant social and economic turbo
and led amongst other things to the
disasters of the Great Leap Forward and
the Cultural Revolution during which
millions died the key characteristics of
the current Chinese model of government
was seemed to me to be an ever-growing
bureaucracy intent on preserving at all
costs one-party rule
recognition that this can only be
achieved if the population at large
believes the economic benefits being
eat outweigh the fact that they have no
say in the selection of those who govern
them an economy that is still largely
command led structured around successive
five-year plans supported by huge
government investment in state
controlled enterprises and
infrastructure vigorous suppression of
dissent through strict censorship and
harassment persecution of any who dare
to speak out against the system or its
injustice and subordination of the
rights of the individual to the wider
public interest as determined by the
state set against this are what I see as
the typical characteristics of a Western
liberal democracy recognition of the
essential role of political parties as
channels for the expression of differing
views within society and a basis for
oddly change of government from time to
time bias towards a predominantly market
layer economy in which the government's
priorities are to nurture innovation
support free enterprise and ensure that
the needs of vulnerable sectors of the
community are met absolute commitment to
the rule of law freedom of thought and
expression protection of individual
rights and freedoms within a just and
fair society there is no doubt that the
Chinese model of government however
described has delivered extremely
impressive economic growth lifting many
millions out of poverty and in the
meantime greatly enriching some but the
speed and scale of China's development
is not exactly unprecedented in more
democratic societies look at the rise of
Great Britain as a global economic power
in the second half of the 19th century
or the emergence of the United States
from the Great Depression of the 1930s
to become the most prosperous and
powerful nation in the world conversely
in the latter part of the 20th century
the Soviet Union socialist model of
centrally controlled economic
development which China initially sought
to emulate collapsed unable to fend off
demands for political reform from within
or compete effectively with a faster
growing market driven economies of the
West to argue that Western liberal
democracy would be bad for China is in
my view and insult to the Chinese people
it implies that they are somehow not
sufficiently grown-up to aspire to
electing their own leaders as opposed to
having them foisted upon them by means
of a highly opaque process of balancing
the various factions within the
governing elite furthermore anyone who
argues that Western liberal democracy
would be bad for China must also be
prepared to acknowledge the perils that
the nation faces if it doesn't begin to
take some genuine steps in the direction
of political reform all around the world
previously unshakeable authoritarian
regimes are being challenged and
overthrown
no wonder China is keeping a nervous eye
on developments in North Africa and the
Middle East
it took the self-immolation of just one
persecuted street vendor to trigger
revolution in Tunisia in Tibet and siege
on the tally of self-immolations
has risen to nearly 60 since 200 9 and
shows no sign of abating the current
Chinese model of government is founded
on the belief that as long as the
economy keeps growing and standards of
living rising stability can be
maintained and the population at large
will tolerate amongst other things an
ever widening wealth gap between the
cities and countryside restriction of
personal rights and freedoms and the
continuing crushing of any form of
dissent this strategy in my view is
fundamentally flawed the current form of
government is under challenge from a
rising tide
not just of discontent but real anger
among sectors of the population that are
increasingly disaffected no one knows
exactly how many incidents of popular
unrest commonly referred to as mass
incidents are occurring some estimates
put it at a hundred and eighty thousand
into old one one whilst others believe
that this is just the tip of the iceberg
little wonder that China is now spending
more on internal security than on the
funding of its military popular anger
and increasingly bold resistance to
government authorities is being fueled
by forced land acquisitions arbitrary
land grabs by provincial officials often
to make way for totally unnecessary
development empty high-rises and
shopping malls
roads to nowhere the collapse of
shoddily constructed schools in the 200
AC - an earthquake tainted baby milk and
other food safety scandals environmental
degradation have led and are leading to
unprecedented confrontations between
ordinary citizens and the government
still all too often instead of
acknowledging shortcomings and
responding to justified concerns the
authority's reaction is to punish the
protesters for disturbing social harmony
corruption is now arrived at every level
of the Chinese political machine power
is concentrated in the hands of a
privileged clique perhaps no more than
400 families who are bound by a common
purpose to protect their mutual vested
interests and capacity for self
enriching the Communist vision of
proletarian supremacy within an
egalitarian state has been subsumed by
greed and injustice exemplified by the
often shameless flaunting by party
Carter's of ill-gotten wealth and a
culture of impunity from moral and even
criminal culpability no one wants to see
China go the way of the Soviet Union in
the aftermath of
desintegration the gains that china has
made in the past three decades are far
too precious to put at risk in an age
when the dissemination of information
via the internet and the blogosphere is
unstoppable to continue to try and
stifle the satisfaction and dissent is
about as futile as King Canute's
legendary attempt to stop the tide
coming in current abuses of power and
the pervading lack of transparency and
accountability simply will not be
tolerated indefinitely everywhere in the
world the need for change is the mention
rather than waiting for popular unrest
to force change China's leaders should
now be actively planning for an orderly
relaxation of its iron grip on political
power and a move towards greater
openness and participatory politics my
conclusion the central government needs
a new model that it can nail its colors
too back in the late 1970's and early
1980s hong kong played a crucial role in
kick-starting china's economic
revolution and the dung shoppings
open-door policy special economic zones
were established on the border with or
in close proximity to hong kong with the
express purpose of inducing hong kong
industrialists to move their
manufacturing operations across the
border where land and labour was so much
cheaper this marked a start of how
southern china Lawford into the factory
of the world
piggy banking on hong kong investment
that provided employment for millions of
migrant workers and provided the formula
to attract wider foreign investment the
hong kong economic model clearly worked
and I believe that the Chinese central
government can and should look to hong
kong to test a new model of more
democratic government that could be
extended progressively into the mainland
thanks to the terms of the sino drawing
british drone declaration
and the concept of one country two
systems' enshrined in our Constitution
the basic law Hong Kong people enjoy the
fundamental freedoms associated with a
modern liberal democracy namely the rule
of law and an independent judiciary
freedom of expression including freedom
of the press freedom of religion freedom
from arbitrary arrest and imprisonment
zero tolerance of corruption the promise
not yet realized of the right to elect
our head of government and legislature
by means of universal suffrage far from
being bad for China it is essential that
the coming leadership in Beijing begin
to draw up a blueprint for reform that
provides Chinese people through a
process of evolution not revolution but
the fundamental rights and freedoms
associated with liberal democratic
government there are plenty of studies
to confirm the link between rising
levels of economic well-being and the
openness of the political system a
democratically based system of
governance will not only sustain China's
long-term economic growth but will also
enrich Chinese society and the world at
large and the perils of not doing so are
becoming increasingly acute so ladies
and gentlemen I beg to a toast motion
before you this evening thank you
so our next speaker speaking for the
motion is Martin Jakes Martin is author
of the book when China rules the world a
senior research fellow at the LSE and a
visiting professor at Ching hua
University in Beijing he tells me his
fascination with China began on a
holiday in southern China in 1993 where
from the sounds of it he fell in love
with both a country and a woman at the
same time in about 30 seconds he told me
Martin
I'd liked owed hasten to add it wasn't
15 seconds it was 30 things as it was 15
minutes and it didn't happen in China it
happened in Malaysia
and my wife-to-be was not Chinese but of
Indian descent India Malaysia so apart
from a few inaccuracies it was
accurately
now I want to clarify first of all what
this motion is about or what it's not
about it's probably the best way of
putting it this is not a proposal that
liberal western-style democracy will
always be inappropriate for China I
don't know what the situation is going
to be like in 25 years or 50 years I
don't even know what the situation is
likely to be in the West in that period
what we're discussing is something much
more specific likewise we're not
suggesting or certainly I'm not
suggesting and the motion is not
suggesting that what happens in China
and the arrangements that are
appropriate for China in this period
should be transplanted into our own
societies I would not argue that for a
moment in fact on the contrary I would
say that the reason Western democracies
have grown up in the West has been
because of the history and the culture
of our societies and we need to pay Jew
respect I would suggest to China and the
differences of its history and culture
in the same way what this motion is
about is a country which is a developing
country which in the middle of the 20th
century was extremely poor which had
suffered 200 years during a 200 year
period of more or less and I mean this
literally economic stagnation its GDP at
the end of this period was more or less
the same as it was in the first part of
the 19th century and it had been invaded
and partially colonized by many
countries including our own in 1949
China was a mess and a basket case and
the task that confronted China was how
with
vast country could they transform it and
they made quite a few false moves and
false starts
so when dong-chil ping came to power in
1978 he identified the two crucial tasks
tasks of China the first was an
overwhelming focus on the need for
economic growth and secondly intimately
tied to that was the need for a huge
reduction in poverty in a
poverty-stricken country at that time in
1978 the Chinese economy was one
twentieth of the size of the American
economy and since that move from the end
of the 70s in the direction of economic
reform we have seen the most remarkable
economic transformation in human history
a population of 1.3 billion people
one-fifth of humanity its economy
growing at 10% a year to the point where
today the Chinese economy is half the
size of the American economy and there's
a general view now that the Chinese
economy will overtake the American
economy in size around about 2018 this
is truly remarkable and I want to
correct you Anson because it's just not
true that the British experience or the
American experience of industrialization
in any way compares with the Chinese
achievement the British industrial
revolution between 1780 and 1830 which
was the key pair or you can push it to
1840 the growth rate was around about on
average one and a half percent a year
one and a half percent a year and that
was a population
what 2030 million at that time probably
more like 20 million at that time or
take America you mention America well
the period between the end of the Civil
War the mid 1860s to 1914 the American
growth rate never exceeded on average
something like 3.5% and that of course
again was a much smaller population so
that is why I suggest that this is the
most remarkable economic transformation
there has ever been and it has been
presided over by the Chinese gun and it
has lifted I mean let's remember this as
well if you look at the reduction in
global poverty over the last thirty
years China is over well is responsible
for the overwhelming bulk of that
reduction in poverty if you take China
out of the equation actually the global
performance has been very disappointing
now I challenge the view that this does
not the Chinese government does not
enjoy the support of overwhelming mass
of Chinese people I don't know you know
if you look at for example the Pew
Global Attitudes surveys the support for
the Chinese government is is
extraordinary impressive if you look at
Tony seichas work from the Harvard
Kennedy School in terms of the levels of
satisfaction amongst the Chinese in
terms of government you know the ratings
are extremely high indeed and is it so
surprising if your living standards are
growing as they have been now for a
while at roughly the same pace of
economic growth 10% a year then you know
it's quite likely that your populate
your population is going to be rather
pleased with with government and I
challenge the idea also that you know
the political of course there are many
things that are different from what
we're used to which we would certainly
object to but the idea that the sort of
political atmosphere the political
environment is frozen is a mistake I
mean the idea that every you know you
said dissent is crushed
excuse me I mean there are about a
hundred and fifty thousand mass
incidents every year in China in which
people which mainly consists of farmers
objecting to what they regard to be the
elicit seizure of their land by local
government flogging it off
to to to property developers and these
actions are well you know they're
reported in lots of places and they take
place and it's not true that they're all
suppressed and sometimes when there is
suppression like in we can actually the
authorities are forced to retreat or
take the wave of strikes in Guangdong
province and in the eastern coast in
Shanghai in 2000 2010 and 2011 tens and
tens of thousands of people on strike
and they were not surprised they were
allowed to happen and the result huge
wage increases the minimum wage in
Beijing was increased during that period
by 30%
Shanghai roughly similar and saw huge
lift in living standard so it's not good
enough I to be frank to paint China as
this sort of autocracy with a central
government which suppresses everything
there has been a huge shift in the
personal freedoms of the average Chinese
since the death of Mao you've only got
to go to Shanghai or to Guangzhou or to
Chengdu and you can see it on the
streets and it's not true that
everything is centered actually the
censorship in China is much lighter than
it used to be much lighter and the
excess to Information sure there are
controls on the internet but quite
frankly if you want to you can get
random so this is a society which is
throbbing actually and it's vibrating
with debate contrary to the picture that
Anson has presented which is a very
common picture presented to Western
audiences um I want you to just say
something else you see my concentration
in what I want to say is really about
China as a developing
now let's take a comparative example
indium in 1950 which has got in many
ways a most impressive democracy in 1950
the Chinese economy and the Indian
economy were more or less the same size
today the Chinese economy is four times
the size of the Indian economy why
because the economic strategy pursued by
the Chinese has been far more successful
than the strategy which has have been
employed by India and India has a great
problem it's got a most impressive
democracy which is what we celebrate and
an extremely corrupt and inefficient
state which cannot deliver in other
words in that sense it's opposite to
China and the poverty reduction in China
has been far anyone who goes to China
goes to and you can see this has been
far more successful that anything that
has been achieved in India now I think
also we need a bit of humility about
this China is a huge as where we pointed
out a huge country on a scale look is
unimaginable to us in the West so we and
whit's task has been how to it has been
in an industrial revolution essentially
economic takeoff as rosto described it
the shift from the countryside to
industry around the time of juncture of
paying it was at not much more than 20%
of the population lived in the urban
centers today it's 50% now what was the
situation politically excuse me in the
West in Europe in the United States when
we were having our industrial
revolutions how many Western countries
were democracies at the time of their
industrial revolutions shall I tell you
how many zero zero in Britain in 1850
finally one-fifth of men had the right
to vote that was after the
lucien of the Industrial Revolution and
it was not until the 1880s that most men
had the vote but not women or take
America it was not until 1860 that most
white men gained the vote but not blacks
really until the 1960s and women in 1920
and if you look at Europe exactly the
same pattern their industrial
revolutions were accomplished
essentially in France in Germany in
Italy and so on before they had
democracy so when so when we say they
should be like us
well actually we should speak we should
speak with more modesty because we
weren't like what we want them to be
during this particular historical face I
would like to conclude by just saying
this first of all I would ask our my my
country to be more modest I'm more
humble in the face of China's
extraordinary achievement and not think
our task is to say why the hell can't
you be like us but on the contrary I
think what we need with the rise of
China is a much more humble attitude
which recognizes risks and respects
their achievement and also is willing to
learn from them
and what we're going to face I think now
is not just feeling that democracy is
important but also we need to learn from
the Chinese about state competence this
is not as subjects that's been discussed
in the West but it will be discussed in
the West and here we have much to learn
from the Chinese thank you very much
so our next speaker speaking against the
motion is Jonathan Mirsky a historian of
China in 1989 named international
reporter of the year for his coverage of
the Chairman's uprising by British that
was the award by British newspapers
Jonathan's interest in China he's
explained to me goes right back from his
parents who lived in Beijing in the
1930s working in the Peking University
Medical Colleges Jonathan it's a
pleasure to have you at the debate
I feel very uneasy about going on about
this because I think Anson as I just
wrote a note to her gave the very best
talk on what democracy and civil rights
are really all about that I've ever
heard in my life I think my friend Roger
Garside may be here do you wait to put
your hands up are you here Roger yes
there he is he wrote a book a long time
ago after Mao's death called coming
alive in Peking when he was in was just
after he'd been in the British Embassy
there it was about democracy wall as it
was called and the man who had been the
great star of democracy what was waging
tion who went to jail for 15 years
thereafter for what was called a
sedition so I'm not here to say that the
American or the British model of
democracy is the best or even a model
I'm certainly not going to say when
Martin Jake said that we have to learn
that a bad a bad model of democracy is
Italy but we could think about Iceland
or Sweden or Norway now what I really
have in mind is this for four years when
I was in a kind of second stage of
learning about China I lived in China
and there was a very brutal dictator in
charge he had a terrifying wife there
were a lot of political prisoners there
was no free press it was really very
scary if you were a Chinese then that
dictator died and before long his son
took over and that place is now a
democracy that's Taiwan it's full of
Chinese who wanted really what in fact
had been denied to them for many years
and after that I worked in China for
many years and over and over again in
Tiananmen and then lots of other times
and places in China
I saw the Chinese the need of many
Chinese as they expressed for these
models of a kind of democracy a free
press
that's not stifled that you can say what
it's like and can even be pornographic
and wrong and libelous and scabrous that
there should be free speech that aside
from again from slander and things of
that kind in racist remarks that there
should be free speech that there should
be freedom of assembly that people in
get together in groups in fact it's what
it's what Obama said last night in his
speech that what you see in America is
the argument for political change
impossible in China today but a good
thing regular elections that people know
are going to happen you might get a
terrible leader you might get a good one
you you can't be sure but at least
people can get rid of the government or
they know it'll go away after a while
and above all the rule of law something
really predictable and then I think is
it just it's the thing I was thinking
about in the cab coming over a real
education so that if you meet young
Chinese who are the elite who were here
at the LSE or at Oxford or Cambridge and
if you say to them what happened in ten
on one Square in 1989 they say it was a
riot and bad people shut down our army
and our police that's what they've been
taught in school and there are many
examples of that kind of thing so what
we see is that on the Chinese internet I
just did this today to see what the
words were that you can't get it or not
they're not available you can't you
can't read about one job out of the
premier who turns out to be in a family
of billionaires the word Taiwan can't
appear in the Chinese internet unless
you're very good at dodging around it or
democracy Tibet Dalai Lama if you use
any of those words there can be a knock
on the door and you can go inside it's
true that you can say things you can say
things in restaurants or you can say
things outside and then all of a sudden
something happens so that if you're the
Nobel Prize winner Lee
Shabbo you go into jail for about 11
years or AI weiwei the man who helped to
design the Olympic Stadium is a man who
now can't leave China there is no real
concerted political action if you try
that as intend on mine and in the 300
other cities where there were big
demonstrations in the spring of 1989 if
you try that the people who have tried
that concerted political action may or
may not go to jail or they may be shot
down or what we just heard about the
Standing Committee that's about to be
unveiled that's what's about to happen
in China they're about to have seven or
nine new men new men always they're
being unveiled now I think there is 700
of you here I wonder if there are 20
people in this room who can name one
name of those people who are going to be
running China in in the next 10 years
and most Chinese are the same they have
never heard of most of these people and
they will discover who they are after
they've been unveiled in law the Chinese
statement is verdict first trial
afterwards and that happens over and
over again so that for instance when the
wife of a man who's now also been
disgraced who was about to go onto the
Standing Committee what she lied she she
was accused of murdering the British
businessman Hayward she read out what
was the charge against her it all been
it had all been written down for her at
her trial and then she was condemned and
as I say in education if you ask Chinese
now what they know about their own past
it's very very little and if you ask
them what they think happened in certain
great events or what they think of the
Dalai Lama or about what goes on in
Tibet they'll give you the government
line
so these are the things that I think are
the big problems that free speech some
kind of Community Action a free press
all of these things wouldn't change
these things but they would start to
make it possible to think about changing
them the enormous gap in China between
rich and poor which is very well
expressed in mr. Jake's book the vast
official corruption which is what the
Chinese say when they're polled by Pew
is it is the thing that they regard as
the most important problem the one-child
system which may be now about to be
changed which has led to a very
unbalanced society in which they were
far too many old people and young people
are going to have to support huge
families and very very old I think we'll
talk some more about this in the
question-and-answer session so what I'm
not saying is that we have the model
here or that we in the West have solve
these problems but these problems about
corruption about the violence of the
state about the fact that Mao Zedong's
portrait still hangs over Chen on one
square can you imagine that happening in
Germany with Hitler or in Cambodia with
Pol Pot and it's really revolting isn't
it so I think that we can discuss all
this in the question and answer period I
look forward to that I'd like to say one
more thing if I were a Chinese and I
said any of the things that I've just
said here to you tonight and I said
these things in China I go straight to
jail tomorrow and I'd be in jail for
years and years and years it's a great
thing isn't it that we can say these
things here or that my Chinese
colleagues can say what they want to say
here they can say it and nothing will
happen if I tried saying these things
and I were a Chinese in China today I'd
be tomorrow I'd be behind bars so think
about that to think how you would like
it if you were a Chinese thanks
so that's the formal proposes for and
against the motion
let me now announce to you what your
views were as you walked into the hall
before the debate began those of you
voting for the motion let's to say those
of you believing that Western liberal
democracy would be wrong for China 228
those against the motion 202 and those
in the don't know category which we hope
will be 0 at the end of the debate 196
so there's 196 minds out there to shape
panelists you've now got a chance to
answer some of their questions so let me
open it up to you questions comments if
they're comments they're going to have
to be very brief yes over just right in
front of you a gentleman's holding his
hand up yep hi one of the key things for
that it's dimension of the legitimacy of
the Chinese government is the amount of
growth in China which is historically
unprecedented why is China growing so
fast I'd love to understand that bit
better great and next if if you can come
up to the middle here the lady with her
hand up
I've just got a couple of quick comments
to make firstly whilst the economic
growth has been unprecedented in China
over the last 30 years it seems it's
becoming increasingly untenable with the
civil riots have been taking place
they've increased tenfold in the last 10
years from what I understand to over
about 150,000 per year surely that's a
sign of growing civil unrest and
secondly I just want you to make a point
to say that the function of the state is
to serve the people but if the people
can't create consensus or participate
with decisions of the state then surely
the state isn't serving the country's
true interests thank you up here to the
gentleman in the front during the Great
Leap Forward by initiative and might see
Tong in 1958
it's estimated that 38 million people
died of starvation and it seems to me
that an authority in authoritarian
regime such as China is fundamentally
ill-equipped to prevent a repetition of
such a catastrophe thank you I'm going
to take one more question and then come
to the panelists just back there the
gentleman with his hand up if you have
to make a comparison are chinese more
like asian roman or asian greek in two
weeks so panelists why is China growing
so fast oh I think the year that the
growth has been largely led by exports
and by investment much of it
increasingly state directed investment
and I should point out
the sort of double-digit growth that has
been sustained in the past few decades I
doubt very much whether they can be
sustained in the longer run because
there is a cost there is a price to be
paid for this type of growth and you
need also to look at the quality of
growth what the the strong growth has
resulted in is that the leadership has
not been particularly successful as they
themselves on to to move away from
export and investment to consumer
spending and stimulating a domestic
demand they have not succeeded in this
the the fixed income investment in 201 1
was equivalent to 50% of GDP that now
that is not a particularly efficient use
of resources and the growth has resulted
in over capacity particularly in
infrastructure and in property it has as
I pointed out led to growing income
disparity to very serious environmental
degradation and these are the costs that
future generations of Chinese will have
to pay Martin wasn't the question was it
I thought the question was why has China
been growing so quickly yes and I think
that's a very a polite question and it's
not so simple to give you the answer I
mean I think there are there must be a
whole cluster of reasons for it that's
not just one or two first of all I think
that there was clearly enormous pent up
possibility in China I mean China
historically until the beginning of you
know till the mid 19th century and the
opium wars and so on China had been a
remarkably successful economy I mean in
1800 it had as average living standards
on a par with northwest Europe and
before that it had a living standards
much higher and it was a much more
developed economy so clearly within the
Chinese historical experience was a
great potential and possibility
secondly I think that the what they
began to do was to learn to learn not
just from the West but to learn from and
not just Hong Kong either but to learn
from East Asia I mean the most
remarkable successful economies in this
period were in East Asia like Korea like
Taiwan and so on and I think the Chinese
and enjoying this period learned a great
deal thirdly the state under dong Xiao
ping was remark was remarkably pragmatic
in his approach remarkably very
pragmatic and very non ideological which
and this was the new example and it's
set to order for the Chinese and that's
how I think many many many Chinese get
many young p.m. et today are very very
pragmatic and a fantastically good
learners and I think this is what China
has been and my last point for this now
would be to just say there is a the
Chinese don't go on about a China model
but it does have to I think particular
characteristics which are most unusual
one is a enormous commitment to the
market a ferocious market I mean Adam
Smith writing in the late 18th century
said the Chinese market is far more
developed than anything we've ever seen
in Europe or that we have in Europe but
that is combined with an extraordinary
state it's a ubiquitous state it has it
this is not just in the communist period
this is a long Chinese tradition running
back into the Imperial through the
Imperial period and the Chinese state
takes on responsibilities which are much
much wider than is anything is true of
our own tradition and is historically
not just now historically an extremely
competent institution so I think that is
a particular paradigm with we're going
to be exploring for a long time to come
Thank You Martin wait wait 38 million
died of starvation I mean the work of a
march of sin and Jean Dre's tells us
that that doesn't happen when you've got
democracy
in the first place Great Leap Forward
was a tragedy and every win China knew
about this but what's important was
actually the person who drew more or
less in there others was not other than
ten selfie he drew so much lesson that
he began this gigantic reform which put
this into an a kind of never will happen
again
so when we talk about this length of
growth speed of growth it's important
that the Chinese state competence to put
a given example whoever planned seventy
years started in 1970 to 2050 and within
this seventy year clever five year plan
five year plan this kind of strategic
planning creates tremendous what I call
long-term demand unprecedented in human
history so in China if you look at the
growth of people's wealth it's a
revolution now just with all respect to
modern change I was in Hong Kong first
hand three decades ago full of
admiration but today you went to hunger
any time if you you find in the housing
condition was so poor compared with most
Chinese live in the cities
no just an example to show that and this
issue concerning yeah oh sorry I should
be closing my and also by the way
concerning this famine it's also
happened during the British colonialism
you have a potato famine island you have
a Bangalore family British India when
pencil population died so each country
perhaps has some ugly part of its
history we have to be honest with that
the problem is whether you can deal with
it yet now China has succeeded in
dealing with that we can export and now
concern this allegedly how many rights
and channels is somehow unstable
actually
I don't worry about this at all you know
in the first place I don't know exactly
how accurate this figure is but what's
more important is the gas use our
argument comes in civilizational state
in Chinese we have a saying France wrong
history we're opposed to the local
officials but not the Emperor you know
so all these so-called a hundred
thousand case is 99% happen in the very
grassroots in the village whatever and
they are not telling the central
government even provincial government is
sufficient to pacify the situation so
this is very very not be good I think
I'm less and more concerned with British
summer rights rather than this one
indeed and yeah yeah I think Channel has
found its own mode of development which
is very effective which is broadly
supported within China I think along
with this model around is coming Party
Congress we can expect within a decade
China's economy will be larger than the
US economy and furthermore was more
important it's highly likely by that
time ten years from now
China's real middle class I mean
economic standards decent job plus a
property will be twice of the American
population which means 600 million
people thank you a way Jonathan Mirsky
Romans or Greeks sorry am I in the right
hole
I'd like to answer your question I'd
like to answer your question about what
happened I mean why so fast I'll just
give you one little brief fact take a
look at a recently published book by H
woman called pi Xiao Hong call shelf of
sand she estimates that 45 percent of
China's GDP is the work of displaced
peasants who are working in China cities
with no rights at all no medical
treatment no education so these are
hardly the recognized citizens of China
so do do if you'd like to check that out
do as for here's his another possibility
if China is the presence of China were
so advanced as in some sense they were
in the 18th and 19th century
what did dung Xiao ping do he got out of
their way he didn't do anything he just
let them produce and that's what jobs a
young a man who was originally who was
in the end was put under house arrest by
done he pointed out that in the province
where he was the party secretary that
the peasants were taking their land back
and that their production was going way
up so the Chinese who are no more or
less hard-working than anyone else have
simply when they've been given the
chance have produced a lot and the right
list Chinese those people from the farms
who first went down to the failing
factories in the south and now work in
the city with no rights are the people
who have produced a lot of the GDP thank
you and I'm going to say that's enough I
didn't understand what you meant about
Greece and Rome by the way we'll come
back to that um more questions so if you
can come over to this side now we've
been biased to the side up to the front
sorry I'm interested Martin Jax you said
that perhaps at some point in the near
or distant future China might be right
for democracy and what what changes
would have to happen and what really
would represent the the tipping element
for that great if you can pass the man
behind you with the orange sweater
ensign Chen I assume you reached your
powerful position without being voted in
by a single Hong Kong resident why do
you think the UK thought it was wrong
for Hong Kong to have liberal democracy
even the last Governor Chris Patten was
imposed upon you was that a mistake a
question it's why so the question the
question is why did Britain think that
it was wrong for Hong Kong to have
direct democracy but we'll come back
we'll come to the answers in a moment
further questions so at the the hand in
the middle of this block here right
across we've heard a lot about being by
for and out of the people but China as
the speakers clearly shown is a nation
for the people as you can see by the
huge amount of people that been left out
of poverty but America a nation
supposedly founded on being by for and
of the people we've just seen an
election funded almost entirely by
special interest groups really from Big
Oil the NRA rich and evangelical
Christians and the funding radical
candidates they can choose and where
both of the candidates attended the same
university so how I ask you is that by
foreign of the people in any sense more
than it is more than the Chinese are
thank you and any further questions I'm
looking at that towards the back of the
hall so that you're not disempowered by
geography but um thank you yep is Tibet
today what Czechoslovakia was in 1938
that if China continues to grow are we
going to receive the treatment which is
currently being meted out to the
Tibetans
so is Tibet today what checkers of
Archaea was in 1938 was that last
question and we'll take one more
question just down here I'll come to you
in the next lot yes thank you I respect
what the others have said but it seems
to me the only person who's tried to
argue the motion is Zhang Wei Wei the
others have merely made comments about
China which are wholly respect and I
think the core of Zhang Weiwei's
argument is that China is so big and so
diverse that mass political parties
wouldn't work and that seems to be the
key distinction because Nobi didn't had
eyes that there should be more rule of
law less corruption and more of a Free
Press etc etc I don't suppose owing Wei
Wei denies that at all
the key distinction is mass political
parties and I think Wei was angry Wei
has argued that they just wouldn't work
have I grasped it correctly thank you so
let's let's take the first and last
questions together is China too big for
democracy and what changes are necessary
for China to be ripe for democracy which
was aimed at Martin who would like to
jump in okay
I think my name is Martin hmm um I
challenge that I must say what a
contrary tear you are um well I I'm
absolutely sure that over time China as
it has been over the last thirty years
will become more open more transparent
more representative more accountable and
as the population you know was for so
long obviously focused on basically
survival and then you know trying to get
a better living standards in situation
of poverty as it as its living standards
greatly improve and lifestyle improves
they're faced with a range of choices
and that will influence the whole
culture and the politics of China the
question is this is the question what
will it look like will that will that
take the form of what we're what we call
western-style democracy or will it take
some other form and I really don't know
the answer to it but the question that
was put to you was what are the changes
necessary for China to be ripe for
democracy just whatever kind of
democracy that is what should we excuse
me that's exactly what I've just been
talking about so what so what will those
changes be in one what well they are
yeah they are about rising living
standards and the transformation of
people's lives and conditions and
possibilities and choices and
opportunities so I I do subscribe to the
view that as China becomes more
prosperous then pressures for for
greater democratization will greatly
increase now what the quickly that you
are you asked another question which is
what will it be like what all those what
will a chinese democracy be like and i
am i think that you know factors like
what Weiwei's been talking about which
is the sheer size of china and the
diversity of china play here because
actually no sub global system which in a
way is what china is
has been a democracy you know the
European Union is a new democracy so
size is a serie is a serious factor not
necessary compelling factor but it is
serious factor in relationship to it now
the other point I want to make is this
there's no tradition in China of popular
sovereignty there never has been
likewise by the way there's not really a
serious tradition of popular sovereignty
in Japan Japan in my view has a bolt-on
western-style democracy but actually
what really happens is state sovereignty
which is accepted in Japan and China
it's a Confucian tradition and so Japan
is really run by its state bureaucracy
although it appears to be like a
western-style democracy and I think it's
quite possible that you know what will
happen in China will be that there will
be all sorts of new forms of expression
and popular expression and so on but
because Chinese history because of the
way Chinese see it state sovereignty
will still in large measure lie at the
heart of whatever China becomes I just
want to say one other thing great
question great question on Hong Kong and
the fascinating paradox is that it will
be in 2017 it looks as if the chief
executive will be elected by the Hong
Kong population which is something that
the British did not achieve in 150 years
yes absolutely
um so Anson Chan would you like to
respond okay
yes but I like to ask a martynuk
question
if and when China is ready for democracy
does he also envisage the disintegration
of the one-party system rule it's and if
so when well I don't know when it is a
possibility I mean nothing is forever
nothing is eternal so with respect that
is not the motion before us the motion
actually says Western liberal democracy
would be bad for China it doesn't put a
time frame well nobody is advocating a
quantum leap at the moment what we're
saying what I'm saying at least is that
there should be an evolutionary process
to democracy as there was in Hong Kong
and you mentioned that in the year 2017
Hong Kong will have universal
suffer'd I think that remains very much
to be seen I doubt very much whether
there will be genuine one-man one-vote
but I would be delighted to be proven
wrong okay can I answer that question I
think it depends on what you mean by
democracy hmm
I don't think democracy centers just on
one man one vote I'm willing to concede
that at this stage maybe one man one
vote is a little too early but there are
the other aspects of democracy which I
believe to be important for all nation
and for all human beings and that is
human dignity some basic rights and
freedoms the right to participate in the
governance to improve the quality of
governance to have some say in issues
that affect their everyday life to have
the rule of law not the rule of men not
rule by law and to have an independent
judiciary that is not subject to the
dictates of the one-party system rule
now III agree with Martin that in the
three thirty years since open-door
policy there has been phenomenal
economic growth there has been a degree
of personal freedom and social mobility
but the sad fact is that in recent years
market economy reforms have stalled and
the government has backtracked on legal
reforms or judicial organs in China are
now subject to the dictates of the
one-party system rule do we seriously
think that the population that the 1.3
billion people in mainland China are
content to accept this you say that
there are mass support for the one-party
system rule why is it then that we get
people in from mainland coming to Hong
Kong to participate in demonstration
particularly against the blind dissident
jung yong who was alleged to have
committed suicide and senchan could you
could you answer the question
I will I will gladly answer the question
first of all I like to point out I was
not a politician therefore I was not
elected I was a civil servant and I was
elected I hope I was appointed as a
result of a series of competitive
examinations I like to think that the
recruitment ball recruited me because
they saw some potential me I did not owe
my appointment nor my subsequent
promotion to political patronage and and
after I retired I was democratically
elected I did participate in a
by-election to the Legislative Council
and I want
weh-weh well I will see a few words on
this issue of one-party system you know
I think indeed - in the same China that
have to move a bit away from our own
European experience or whatsoever
Westing experience if you have to apply
this concept one-party I can say you
know over the past
2,200 years 99% of the time China was on
the one-party rule except who had tried
Republican and revolution and then the
country degenerate into chaos and civil
wars and of this 2200 years Chan was
indeed we head of Europe for 1700 years
we missed Industrial Revolution and they
were became that word when over the past
three decades China indeed catching up
very fast so the Chinese one party this
party has nothing to do with
conservative party labour party it's a
continuation of the older tradition in
China what we call the unified state
Confucian stage at the center of the
Chinese States all will unify the
political entity based on meritocracy
officials were selected thousands of
years passing competitive exams and
further from that wait listen can I pick
up the question that the two of the
audience brought to you which so your
argument with as they understood it was
that China is too big for democracy and
your debating partners argument is that
China is not yet ripe for democracy
what's your view is it that it's too big
and not right or but it's we're also
both first simply too big too diverse
actually to practice western-style
democracy it's a suicidal vote on
country well break up overnight yeah we
had experienced earlier trials again to
be honest you ask 10 Chinese 9 will tell
you it's unbelievable unimaginable China
have so-called modern parties every four
years you change the central government
its 1.3 1.4 billion people it says
it's no joke you have to go it's a
gradual process actually I'm not
thinking you know China is really moving
towards western-style democracy that's
not the right word we're very confident
we can compete with wealth in political
system I'm writing an article which
hopefully work in New York Times in the
coming days called America tock receiver
see democracy China may win yeah this
meritocracy is wonderful we had this for
solid of years and we really draw a lot
from European experience so we called
meritocracy in bracket selection plus
election it functions very well thank
you
I'm any panelist willing to give us 30
seconds on Tibet is Tibet today what
Czechoslovakia was in 1938 do I have any
takers Jonathan perhaps this is aimed at
youth am i giving you the hardest
questions Jonathan and I've bent at
about six times the Chinese tried very
hard Chinese occupation tried very hard
to smash Tibetan Buddhism and the way of
life it hasn't worked it hasn't worked
that's why Tibetans are setting
themselves on fire in all the times that
I was in Tibet if you got to know what
Tibetan a little bit he'd take a picture
of the Dalai Lama out of his pocket and
kiss it or press it to his head so just
that alone is one of those things that
if I were a Chinese I would feel ashamed
of myself about but that's not really
what I want to say at the moment what
I'd like to say is this it's enough to
make anybody weep to think that it has
now been forgotten that in nineteen
nineteen eighty nine and ten on one
there were hundreds of thousands of
people in Tiananmen and in 300 other
Chinese cities and what were they saying
da da dong Xiao ping down with Deng
Xiaoping smashed on joking
leepung the premiere shot I get off and
they were shouting out for democracy
smashed by tanks
hundreds of people were killed lots of
people are still in jail from Chen on
Mon the word is taboo when the Internet
it can't be mentioned it's deadly and
young Chinese have now bought into that
because they don't know any better
the second thing is about piu the the
pollsters in their most recent poll what
they've said is that 70 percent of
well-educated urban Chinese admire the
American system of democracy and what
did Tony say CH who's been invoked here
also at Harvard say in his most recent
thing I just read it today
the paternalism of the Maoist state
retains a strong influence in China
today the infantilization of society is
still being managed the leadership
continues to act as if it is the parent
and the Chinese people are the child now
that's what Tony sage who was invoked
today really thinks about what's going
on in China but it really makes me weep
to think that all those Chinese who over
the years desperately wanted democracy
and by that I mean freedom of speech
press assembly all those things which is
the Leo Chou ball to jail for 11 years
that that's all been wiped out it's not
that they don't want it it's not that
they're too big of course they want it
those who know about it of course they
want it is the same way that anybody in
this room would like to have that with
all of the facts here that defects in
America which I left because of the
Vietnamese war despite that the fact is
that people can jump up and down they
can coalesce they can form parties it
can write in the newspapers Chinese
cannot do that the society would not
fall apart if that happened what would
happen is that the party which is hardly
mentioned here tonight which is called
the state the party might be hauled out
that would be a very good thing for
China thank you now we're moving
when moving rapidly into our final
straight so let me just remind you that
you're going to soon have a little box
thrust in front of you to vote and you
are all going to vote so you're going to
take your ticket we're going to rip it
in half and you're either going to vote
for the motion or against the motion
based on how much you've been persuaded
by the arguments that have been put to
you tonight to assist you in that
process I'm going to ask each panelist
for their two-minute takeaway the two
minute thought that they want you to
leave this hall having resonating in
your ears and we're going to go in
reverse order to their opening speeches
so Jonathan oh I feel I've had my say I
donate my two minutes to answer wow she
gets four minutes Martin well my my part
my parting thought for you is only
adjacent to what we've been discussing
but it because I think what we've been
discussing raises a much more much wider
question which is we don't really
understand China and we as Westerners
try and understand China through a
Western prism and we expect our agenda
with regard to China to be the agenda
which the Chinese should follow and we
get very frustrated and impatient when
that doesn't happen and it's not going
to happen because actually we need to
understand China in its own terms we
need to understand and respect the
history and culture of what is an
entirely different phenomenon to
anything that is encompassed by the
Western experience China I would argue
for example is although it has called
itself a nation-state as a result of
weakness around about 1900 is not
primarily a nation state it is a
civilization state and it's a
civilization state which works in entire
only different way the notion of
identity of the Chinese is not a
function of nation as it is with
Westerners it's a function in the first
instance overwhelmingly of it of their
relationship to civilization so their
sense of awareness their sense of
identity is fundamentally different why
do you know why do why do the Chinese
have such a different attitude towards
Westerners to the state the reason is
because the structure of the
relationship between state and society
in China is profoundly different as a
consequence of the fact that the Chinese
feel the function of the state above all
is its relationship to maintain the
unity and the well-being of Chinese
civilization
so therefore the Chinese view of the
state is not like as we view it with
certain amount of suspicion and
certainly a lot of restraint the Chinese
don't see it like that for the Chinese
the state is the family writ large and
therefore they see the state rather like
the head of the family now this is so
different from the Western tradition and
this is our great challenge I think over
the 21st century because China is going
to become the largest economy in the
world it's going to become hugely the
most influential projections 2030 other
China will be responsible one-third of
global GDP where America will be
responsible for roughly 70% what's the
great challenge facing Westerners for
the next century the task is to
understand and make sense of China
because the world will become less and
less Western and more and more China
centric thank you
Martin
Anson Chan um no to minutes will do I I
think Martin I won't be right that
sooner rather than later China will
become the largest economy in the world
it will have increasing economic clout
and will seek to use is so-called soft
power so against that background all the
more important that what happens within
China how its people are treated how
those in power govern because they do
have an impact on Hong Kong on the rest
of the world at this stage of China's
development where we talk about
democracy as I said earlier in reply to
a question we're not saying you should
move straight to multi-party system rule
we're not saying there should be one man
one vote but we are saying that the
people Chinese people are no different
from all human beings on this planet
they one human dignity they want
participation in government they want
fair just society in which the growing
economic wealth of the nation as a whole
is equally shared in the same way as
they are expected to share in the pain
when there is an economic downturn it is
anybody's guess whether the phenomenal
year average ten percent growth achieved
in the past three decades are going to
be sustained I rather think not the
point is that China is at a stage of
development where to sustain economic
growth to achieve real social harmony
there has got to be reforms on the
political side
leaders often doubt the importance of
maintaining harmony but harmony cannot
be subject to the dictates of the ruling
party
how many only comes when every
individual the masses feel that they are
fairly treated at the moment we see
actually two classes of people look at
the way that migrant workers who do not
have Huckel are treated they don't have
access to education to a lot of other
social welfare services you have a
growing income disparity at least in the
early days of the communist takeover
those in the rural population did see a
significant improvement in their
standard but in recent years the income
disparity between those in the urban
areas and those in the countryside are
not narrowing they are widening we have
massive overcapacity we I think we have
a looming difficulty over non-performing
loans because there has been vast credit
expansion particularly following the
Wall Street collapse in 208 so for the
sake of all of us I think Chinese
leaders and I hope that the new log
leaders coming in will have the vision
the foresight the courage and the
political clout to initiate political
reforms in order to underpin Hong Kong
and China's long-term prosperity thank
Shango where you get the last word you
get two minutes that's not four which is
what Anson Chan had thanks to the
generosity of her fellow panelists thank
you actually the success of China can be
summarized in one remark by Deng
Xiaoping's
which is called seeking choose from
facts he just so common sense you check
with any Chinese you meet in London in
Europe in Beijing in Shanghai in China
United States I can tell you by my
minimal estimation eighty percent
diversity to this China is best time
China's own history just common sense
approach whatever opinion surveys you
conducted even human rights so seek
truth from facts even on this
controversy of the Freid of the media
freedom press you know my goodness you
can press any button check international
it have fun a huntress all the articles
criticizing China garden on the Chinese
websites yep it's just so part of common
sense it's vibrating with internal
debate on all kinds of issues it's
totally different from the past
foreign time when Jonathan was in China
now there are alleged so-called the
persecution of certain dissidents and
these are really the radical of the
radicals by Chinese and
even the Chinese approach' to them is
I'm afraid you know it pales a lot or
much in comparison with the Americas
persecution of wiki League and asan G no
comparison
well one final remark in 1793 British
king sent an envoy to China and had a
audience with Chinese emperor the
Chinese emperor was so arrogant is the
channel with the best his end of the
history Chinese version so China missed
Industrial Revolution and China began to
sharp decline West unfree is making same
mistake really
I hope West will be alarmed to this fact
in this sense I agree with Martin thank
you thank you very much
the votes are being counted but while
they are being counted we have time for
a couple more comments now I'm aware
that we didn't get any from this corner
or up the back there so is there anyone
dying to make a comment yes they're
right in front of you oh oh okay please
stir um I always get quite nervous when
everyone says that China is going to
carry on growing because that's exactly
the kind of reasoning that had people
had behind the whole subprime mortgage
crash and China is doing very well
politically when they're growing at 10%
but at some point they're going to have
to combat recession or at least slow
growth I feel that if you don't you know
if when people hit recession and that's
when people feel they need an outlet for
their anger you're saying that 80% of
people support the government what
happens when only 20% of the people
support the government when they have a
recession how is the one party
government going to deal with that
that's my worry about China thank you
we're not gonna have time for answers
but this lady here had one last comment
Jim was addressed by an some chance so
it was all really about human rights and
that everybody should have the
opportunity to be able to vote to be
able to pen the word and all the things
that an sunshine has said I agree with
wholeheartedly and I just like to say on
behalf of the entire room that I think
the debate has already been won by you
say thank you yeah and with just to
lengthen the suspense by 30 seconds I'm
going to get 30 seconds to the lady here
in the scarf Thank You Larry
um I think we should at least have one
person from China's younger generation
to speak here as a Chinese I feel
thrilled that there's opinion that China
is going to roll the century very soon
and it feels really good to be able to
vote but my question is does economic
growth or remarkable achievement as
Marty
but it really justify the flaws in the
current political system in China and is
the current political system really
enables every citizen or at least the
majority of the population in China to
share the fruit of economic development
thank you thank you very much and now
the debate result so the good news for
Martin and Weiwei is that they have
persuaded one person in the room to
change their mind voting for the motion
were 229 people you'll recall there were
228 before you came in now voting
against the motion persuaded by Anson
Chan and Jonathan Mirsky 362 that's a
that's a lot of swing voters and a lot
of committed voters swinging and the
result I as chair and most thrilled
about is that only 24 people decided
that they didn't know so a huge thank
you do we know we are live and we're
going to come and get you later you
decide good thank you
you